well hell let's just pause for just a
second here yeah I'm wondering can you
guys pretend at your back in production
okay I don't know how to go bad why no
its you know very gentle and we'll do
some you know of course express you know
techniques well it ends up if you were
going to fill the scene in this room
Jeff can you sort of set up the scene
you know take us through your thought
process sure yeah well first of all you
just got to just look at where your
light is you know if you can't light it
you gotta follow the light and that's
real light you know unless you're going
for something really dramatic you know
but you know your ideology what do you
what you want to look like and then
follow the light source and then line up
any kind of elements that you can use to
make it interesting or appealing
geometric shape or distribution of items
wait to the whole composition and then
double check everything then triple
check out here we'll check everything
because we had no room for mistakes hmm
hey actors a lot a lot of these things
were there's only one one tape or new
with no time so we had a triple check
yeah reflections etc but yeah I'm
composition and light and any chance for
a dynamic looking shot you know yeah
what about actors that move around a lot
or that was rough sometimes you know we
had we had you know sometimes for for a
real up close and personal effect i was
shooting it like 1.4 so you get an actor
that's going like this even like a half
an inch and it's like won't won't won't
so that was a real challenge sometimes
sometimes I had literally close-up I had
a whole lot of their shoulder and then
just get the headshot I don't like that
but um moving actors yeah it's a concern
on you you had to move a lot because I
haven't definite I was definitely which
I was going to that could be his pain
was just you you would stop a scene and
everybody's first instinct because
nobody has experience being on set
everybody's
instinct is to like go over here or grab
something or you know and you know we
want to stay I mean you got the wheel on
the follow focus marked for their spot
and you got to reset everything that was
frustrated so just you know just
everybody just starting at the same time
you know between the actors and the
couple grips that we had it was it was
learning experience all the way through
for sure we learned a lot yeah what are
your tips on working with an actor
that's never been you had to get
uncomfortable yeah um talk to them for a
while you know I mean that's key you
have to get uncomfortable and downs what
makes you direct them where you want
them to look teach them about sight
lines and things like that ya mean I I
think I think the key or leasing are you
know with with our project we wanted to
give the actors a lot of Liberty to try
whatever came to mind like let's toast
stick stick to the script but if you
want to take it into production go for
it so we would then set up guidelines
like okay here's where we cannot go or
where we're now going to run into
problems for the camera or yeah audio um
like draw a straight line from the lens
to that truck and for the lens to that
tree and you can move anywhere in there
don't go past this yeah so and then we
would try like we would set up the
natural the direction that we wanted the
actors to move in but allowed it to sort
of organically take place for some of
the movie shots but a lot of our shelter
posted up on sticks though so you know
it was mostly a lot of it was with
stationary which yeah especially when
you have one chance or two chances
that's really a lot more reassuring mm
to work that way but that's that's it
that's a key point because uh another
reason why we shot the film what we did
was because of the budget so we did do a
lot of closer shots medium shots where
people were still yeah
I when we just had no crew yeah we we
had nobody to even hold a reflector
sometimes you know so there's just no
room for movement sometimes when you
when you don't have anybody to help you
out um I mean yeah it was it was tough
but we we did our homework but we also
we got very lucky it's true all right a
lot we grew a lot I mean we again we
were just discussing last night how they
would be amazing to do it again that
well though we would never want to do it
that way again but it would be amazing
we do everything so much more
efficiently especially on the post
production side of the asset and
distribution but um it's um very much so
in production as well like what time we
just just get more assistance you know
higher production team yeah higher you
know hire people we would hire people I
would that go in knowing what we know
now I would have definitely put more
than on credit cards and so an interns
to buy me new interns for sure and
something we did not use it all really
yeah one day everybody went for free
which is sort of an inherently an
internship but they weren't like college
kids you know you know doing this and
that and we were very lucky with the
crew that we had what we need if we were
do it again which hopefully we never
have to do it again and the way we did
it yeah so the oddities are
hypotheticals but i would definitely
don't money into some key crew positions
and and and i mean just to be able to
have somebody set up lights yeah would
have been awesome there's so much for
for our small group to do and that's why
that's why I mean when I say we're lucky
when there's such a small group of
people managing when there's like two or
three people or two people managing
everything and only like a crew of four
or three or one taking care of all of
the actors
and end equipment there's a lot of room
for for somebody get tired on the track
mileage for you to try finicky Union you
need extra I sometimes just to see
things and it was very high stress
because of that too and just there there
was never a down moment you know it's
not like take five it's like go get the
rest of the gear and set up very quickly
so we can do this until we have the time
to shoot we have the time yeah because
the daylights vain so that we give our
actors an opportunity to try something
and and some of our some of our
locations that said okay yeah you can
shoot you can shoot from noon to one
understand it so we'd get there have
everything set up outside the door as
soon as they unlock that thing we'd be
in there setting it up he's blocking and
then we set up a shot according to he's
blocking and we're vice versa and yeah
and then he has hops into actor role and
then something else he wasn't in yeah
thankfully yeah it would I think would
have been it would have been too much I
was in every scene but I mean we were
Joe and I would constant look she gonna
be like are we good are we good are you
sure we're good i was again out of trust
for each other during the project so
that yep we're trusting each other and
that was the key to as integral i
wouldn't have worked because we didn't
have anybody else checking to make sure
that thing I mean I thought actors
occasionally like okay you guys missed
something or like that sure doesn't look
right for continuity sex or something
but um for the most part like Joe and I
were dial then relying on each other to
make sure one of us picked up on the
mistake and that's what I mean when I
say we're lucky for the production side
you